foreign
track virtually nothing that's happening
in our own brains but in a future that
is coming much faster than you realize
all of that is about to change
we're now familiar with sensors and our
smart watches to our rings that track
everything from our heartbeats to our
footsteps breaths body temperature even
our sleep
Now consumer neurotech devices are being
sold worldwide to enable us to track our
own brain activity as companies from
meta to Microsoft snap and even Apple
begin to embed brain sensors in our
everyday devices like our earbuds
headphones headbands watches and even
wearable tattoos
we're reaching an inflection point in
brain transparency and those are just
some of the company names we're familiar
with there are so many more consumer
neurotech devices are moving from Niche
products with limited applications to
becoming the way in which we'll learn
about our own brain activity our
controller for virtual reality and
augmented reality and one of the primary
ways will interact with all of the rest
of our technology
even conservative estimates of the
neurotech industry put it at more than
38 billion dollars by 2032.
this new category of Technology presents
unprecedented possibility both good and
bad
consider how our physical health and
well-being are increasing while
neurological disease and suffering
continue to rise
55 million people around the world are
struggling with dementia with more than
60 to 70 percent of them suffering from
Alzheimer's disease
nearly a billion people struggle with
mental health and drug use disorders
depression affects more than 300 million
consumer neurotech devices can finally
enable us to treat our brain health and
wellness as seriously as we treat the
rest of our physical well-being
but making our brains transparent to
others also introduces extraordinary
risks
which is why before it's too late to do
so we must change the basic terms of
service for neurotechnology in favor of
individual rights
I say this not just as a law professor
who believes in the power of law nor
just a philosopher trying to flesh out
norms
but as a mother
who's been personally and profoundly
impacted by the use of neurotechnology
in my own life
on Mother's Day in 2017
as my daughter Calista
lay cradled in my arms
she took one last beautiful breath
after a prolonged hospitalization
complications following infections
claimed her life
the harrowing trauma that she endured
and we witnessed stretched into weeks
and I was left with lasting trauma that
progressed into post-traumatic stress
disorder
sleep escaped me for years
as each time I closed my eyes I relived
everything from the first moments that I
was pushed out of the emergency room
to her gut-wrenching cries
ultimately it was the help of a talented
psychologist using exposure therapy and
my use of neurofeedback that enabled me
to sleep through the night
for others who are suffering from
traumatic memories an Innovative new
approach using decoded neurofeedback or
DEC nap may offer reprieve this
groundbreaking approach uses machine
learning algorithms to identify specific
brain activity patterns including those
associated with traumatic memories
participants then play a game that
enables them to retrain their brain
activity on positive associations
instead
if I had had decnaf available to me at
the time
I might have overcome my PTSD more
quickly without having to relive every
sound
hearer and smell in order to do so
I'm not the only one Sarah described
herself as being at the end of her life
no longer in a life worth living because
of her severe and intractable depression
then using implanted brain sensors that
reset her brain activity like a
pacemaker for the brain
Sarah reclaimed her will to live
while implanted neurotechnology advances
have been extraordinary
it's the everyday brain sensors that are
embedded in our ordinary technology that
I believe will impact the majority of
our lives like the one-third of adults
and nearly one quarter of children who
are living with epilepsy for whom
conventional anti-seizure medications
fail
now researchers from Israel to Spain
have developed brain sensors using the
power of AI and pattern recognition and
consumer electroencephalography to
enable the detection of epileptic
seizures minutes
to up to an hour before they occur
sending potentially life-saving alerts
to a mobile device
regular use of brain sensors could even
enable us to detect the earliest stages
of the most aggressive forms of brain
tumors like glioblastoma where early
detection is crucial to saving lives the
same could hold true for Parkinson's
Disease to alzheimer's traumatic brain
injury ADHD and even depression
we may even change our brains for the
better
the brain training game industry worth a
staggering 6.5 billion dollars in 2021
was for years met with controversy
because of unsupported scientific claims
about their efficacy
but now some brain training platforms
like cognifit have proven powerful in
improving brain processing speeds memory
reasoning and even executive functioning
when played repeatedly over time
when paired with neurofeedback devices
for learning reinforcement
this could revolutionize how we learn
and adapt to change
other breakthroughs could be
transformational for The Human
Experience today most human brain
studies are based on a very small number
of participants engaged in very specific
tasks in a controlled laboratory
environment
with widespread use of brain centers the
data we could have to learn about the
human brain would exponentially increase
with sufficiently large data sets of
long-term real-world data from people
engaged in everyday activity we just
might address everything from
neurological disease and suffering to
creating transformational possibilities
for The Human Experience
but all of this will only be possible if
people can confidently share their brain
data without fear that it will be
misused against them
you see the brain data that will be
collected and generated by these devices
won't be collected in traditional
laboratory environments or in clinical
research studies run by physicians and
scientists
instead it'll be the sellers of these
new devices the very companies who've
been commodifying our personal data for
years
which is why we can't go into this new
era naive about the risks are complacent
about the challenges that the collection
and sharing our brain data will pose
scientific hurdles can and will be
addressed in time but the social hurdles
will be the most challenging
unlike the Technologies of the past that
track and hack the human brain brain
sensors provide direct access to the
part of ourselves that we hold back that
we don't express through our words and
our actions brain data in many instances
will be more sensitive than the personal
data of the past because it reflects our
feelings our mental States our emotions
our preferences our desires even our
very thoughts
I would never have wanted the data that
was collected as I worked through the
trauma of my personal loss to have been
commodified shared and analyzed by
others
these aren't just hypothetical risks
take enter attack a hongsu based company
who has collected millions of instances
of brain activity data as people have
engaged in a mind-controlled car racing
sleeping working even using
neurofeedback with their devices
they've already entered into
Partnerships with other companies to
share and analyze that data and less
people have individual control over
their brain data it will be used for
micro targeting or Worse instead of
treating dementia
like the employees worldwide who've
already been subject to brain
surveillance in the workplace to track
their attention and fatigue to
governments developing brain Biometrics
to authenticate people at Borders to
interrogate Crystal to interrogate
criminal suspects brains
and even weapons that are being crafted
to disable and disorient the human brain
wearables will have not only read but
write capabilities creating risks that
our brains can be hacked manipulated and
even subject to targeted attacks
we must act quickly to safeguard against
the very real and terrifying risk to our
innermost selves
recognizing a human right to cognitive
Liberty would offer those safeguards
cognitive Liberty is a right from
interference by others but it is also a
right to self-determination over our
brains and mental experiences to enable
human flourishing
to achieve this we need to recognize
three interrelated human rights and
update our understanding of them to
secure to us a right to mental privacy
to safeguard us from interference with
our automatic reactions our emotions and
our thoughts
freedom of thought as an absolute human
right to protect us from interception
manipulation and Punishment of our
thoughts and self-determination to
secure self-ownership
over our brains and mental experiences
to access and change them if we want to
do so
their important efforts already underway
from the U.N to UNESCO in Nations
worldwide over rights and regulations
around neurotechnologies
but those rights need to be better
aligned by the broader set of digital
rights
cognitive Liberty is an update to
Liberty in the digital age as an
umbrella concept of human flourishing
across digital Technologies because the
Right Way Forward isn't through
metaverse rights or AI rights or
neurotech rights and the like it's to
recognize that these Technologies don't
exist in silos but in combination
affecting our brains and mental
experiences
we are literally at a moment before
and I mean a moment
consumer brain wearables have already
arrived and the commodification of our
brains has already begun
it's now just a question of scale
we haven't yet passed the inflection
point where most of our brains can be
directly accessed and changed by others
but it is about to happen giving us a
final moment to make a change so that we
don't look back in a few years time and
Lament The World we've left behind
we can and should be hopeful and
deliberate about the choices we make now
to secure a right to self-determination
over our brains and mental experiences
possibilities if we do so
are limited only by our imagination
thank you
foreign